>> All right, so that quiz maybe was ill-placed, in
that it was about what this is not about. What
this is about is computational learning theory. And computational learning
theory really gets us a formal way of addressing three really
important questions. One is, what's a learning problem? Let's, let's
define very carefully what it is that we want a
learning algorithm to do. If we can do that, we
can actually show that specific algorithms either work or don't work,
with regard to the definition of the problem. And maybe we
can even come up with algorithms that solve those problems better.
So that's kind of on the upper-bound side. And then on
the lower-bound side we can also show, for example, in some cases
that some problems are just fundamentally hard. So you, you define
a particular learning problem and you discover. Wait, the algorithms that I'm
thinking of don't seem to work. You might actually be able
to show that no algorithms, say, no algorithms in some particular class
are ever going to be able to solve them
because, that problem is not solvable by problems in that
class. So those problems are fundamentally hard. So, answering
these kinds of questions require that you be fairly careful
about defining things and using mathematical reasoning to, to
determine what's going on. So we're going to focus mostly
on that, talk about some algorithms that are not necessarily
practical. You wouldn't necessarily want to use them, but they do
help illuminate what the fundamental learning questions are
and, and why certain algorithms are effective and ineffective.
>> Okay, so Michael, so can I ask you a question then?
>> Sure, please.
>> So, it sounds to me like you've just justified this in the
same way that a computing theoretician might
try to justify theory. Are they related?
>> Right. That's a very good observation. In fact, the, the kinds of
analyses and tools that are used for
analyzing learning questions are also the same
kinds of tools and mechanisms that are used in the context
of a-, analyzing algorithms in computing. So yeah, that's exactly right.
>> Okay, great.
>> In fact, let's let's, let's leverage that analogy.
And we'll do it in the context of a quiz.